i would say in romance
in love you want what's best for the
other person
in romance you want the other person
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense welcome to the
pretty intense podcast
on the show today is gloria steinem
man gloria an 85 year old
icon she's a writer she she almost has
she says she's a hard time pinning down
exactly
what her job is but she's a writer she's
a feminist
she is a part of movements
and my goodness she has some interesting
and sometimes very simple perspectives
on something that were
i don't know i think we all want an
answer and sometimes the simple answer
is not the one we want but sometimes
but i think that that that's what the
truth is and i'm not going to argue with
someone that's 85 years old
so she has a hell of a lot more
experience than i do so
look we talked about life we talked
about what's important
we talked about what the point of it is
and i hope that you find this
just as refreshing as i did
thanks for coming gloria this is um a
really cool opportunity to talk to
someone who
has been so
instrumental in leading the way by being
strong with an opinion and
not falling into the norms really
which is the problem the perpetuation of
the problem
is that you just kind of go with the
flow and um
so thank you for coming and being able
to i could say
and do say exactly the same thing
because you really didn't go with the
norms
i talk about not going with the norms
and and i do
i suppose in my life but not
with the kind of immediacy and danger
that you have done
yeah well i guess there's you know
there's there's there's physical danger
but you know you also are opinionated on
things that create different danger
and um you know danger of judgment
danger of perhaps your own well-being on
some level i mean look you're
you're you're you're standing your
ground on stuff that people don't want
people to stand their ground on and
that's why it is the way it is
um i i've always said to people that
if you don't find what it is that's
unique about you you're not going to
stand out because you're never going to
be the next someone else
like anyone that wants to be they say i
want to grow up and be like you i said
you shouldn't want to grow up and be
like me you should want to grow up and
be better than me
because that's the only way you're going
to get it done well you shouldn't be
yourself
yeah yes that's the key to it right it's
it's not better necessarily
but it's unique yeah just i mean i think
we each come into the world as the
unique
combination of heredity and environment
and you know
that could never have happened before
and could never happen again
and we share our humanity so
the whole idea is to be able to express
what's
unique in us and be supported
by other people so how old were you when
you knew that there was something unique
about you and you had
unique perspectives uh
you know i'm not sure because that
requires self-consciousness
but i think it helped in a way that i
didn't go to school very much
until i was about i don't know
12 or 13. so i was just reading books
and assuming you know that i could you
know
follow my interest i'd i probably missed
a certain amount
of conforming because i i wasn't in
the classroom and and also oddly i don't
know if this will make sense
or not but uh my
mother and both my grandmothers were
theosophists
and the that what is the definition of a
theory well
it just means god knowledge but okay but
it's
it's uh a kind of
spiritual god is in everything not in
one guy you know
belief okay got it uh and it also
they also kind of believe in incarnation
reincarnation okay got it the buddhist
perspective
so yeah sort of even pre-buddhist
because
buddha is in a way monotheism right one
guy okay yeah so
this is this is good no this is great
education
this is also everything flowers bees
people all of nature and so on
uh does it have a name like
okay yeah i don't know if it was like
gaia or
like no it was generally known as
theosophy and it was
sort of i think began in the late 1800s
and it's still around
now that i've told you this you will see
theosophical lodges and cities and so on
for them yeah but because
they uh kind of believed in
in reincarnation then the idea was
that your job as a family was to help
this child
become who they already were and
and and that is you know very helpful
instead of saying you have to be just
like uncle
harry or amen whatever right yeah
wow i mean it didn't keep my mother from
occasionally saying you're just like
your father
what do you believe uh i think i
i i believe that you know that uh
there's godliness mystery life whatever
you want to call it
in all living things and
we make up divisions we make up gender
we make up race we make up class
but we didn't always actually i mean the
old languages
uh were here and the you know on
manahata island
and the the native american languages
didn't have gender they didn't have he
and she
people were people did they have name i
mean they were gone they went with they
had a name
probably is that yeah they were
addressed no everybody
had a uh an individual name
did they was there anything unique about
how they got their name
they i hate to generalize because there
were you know like hundreds of different
tribes and nations but they often waited
until the child did something unique
and and then named the child because
native american names are fairly unique
there yeah so that's
how you got like running there in the
forest yeah right
yeah because they did kind of wait until
you did something unique and then
wow that was your name but although you
also had your clan name
i mean you belonged to a clan but like
your family or your
yeah that was your second name but you
had an individual name
wow that's that's i think we're trying
to get that
yeah because i do feel like there's an
unlearning going on where we're going
back to even
on simple levels of like farm to table
food and growing things again instead of
the big box stores where you
are eating fake food like people there's
there's a movement of getting
back to where we were through um
all kinds of different channels no i
absolutely and
the the period of time that we are in
that is patriarchal hierarchical
racist gendered is quite short
i mean in in this country where we are
it's
600 years and people have been here for
thousands upon thousands of years
so maybe this is just steve and that's
true this could be a little hiccup we're
having right now
um do you believe in reincarnation um i
don't know
i don't know i i just say i don't know
do you feel like you ever have a sense
of familiarity with situations
or um a yearning or a love for something
that you can't explain or that's not
like someone else that you think you
know what
in another life
[Music]
i certainly feel that i'm suddenly in
tune with something
uh and there was once a wonderful huge
novel called the recognitions which was
all about this
by william gaddis and the whole premise
was
that you're you went through life and
recognized
things that you had known before i i
don't know
but i do think whether it has existed
before or not
we suddenly find ourselves
with a kind of consonance or
understanding or you know that goes
along with whoever we are
[Music]
could be an interconnectedness too on a
level that we don't understand i'm at a
physical level that
you know obviously we can't see that but
that it's there that we don't understand
um how we become tethered to each other
how they're you know once there is some
sort of interaction you're forever
um intertwined with people and things in
places
yes we may be the result of all the food
we've ever eaten
and all the uh people we've ever loved
and
known or and all the books we've ever
eat you know
yeah who knows i don't know i think
about the world and it just blows me
away and i'm like where did we come from
and what is all this and what is the
point
where are we going and where did we
where did we come from
um but back to something that you
brought up that for me is a really
a topic that i've talked about and think
about
regularly and that is division
and how
it kind of came to me with the whole
divide and conquer
and in my mind i thought divide and
conquer was like get a team together and
go conquer the world
and now i look at it completely
different to me divide and conquer is
keep people fighting and disliking each
other
and away from each other and we don't
know they don't even know each other
and just give them a reason to not like
someone else so that we can keep
division
that way we keep people small and
certain people stay in power
and so that's how i look at it now but
whether it's race
religion um your political views
shoot the team you cheer for i mean
there are so many things to create
division and i i
i believe it's a it's a great source of
our disconnectedness from each other
we can just put a title on it we don't
have to get to know you because you're
just a this
yeah i i agree totally 100
and i think that where it starts is
controlling reproduction and therefore
controlling
women's bodies because the
the paradigm of old old old cultures
that
some of which are of course still with
us
certainly where we all came from in
africa the quay and the sun
you know or the oldest cultures in india
are the oldest ones here
the paradigm was a circle
not the pyramid so the idea was
that we were linked not ranked
that's a great reference a circle versus
a triangle yeah the triangle has a
difference once you
look at it that way
a lot of things make sense right
yeah and the first step
as far as i know of every hierarchy in
the world
uh ancient or new is controlling
reproduction
and that means controlling women's
bodies obviously such a hot topic with
abortion laws yeah it's still going on
and
and
and not to cite the ultimate
but actually it was the first thing that
the so-called national socialist that's
hitler
did in germany the very first thing he
did
was to well first of all he came to
power
on uh restoring because you know there
had been a lot of
real democracy in in germany between the
wars
and and he came to power on restoring
kinder kirk you know the traditional
role of women children
church kitchen um you were speaking the
german version yeah and when he was
elected the first thing that he did
was to padlock the family planning
clinics and declare abortion a
crime against the state so that
the doctor would be executed the woman
would be imprisoned
because she wasn't executed because she
has
the one thing that men don't have
which is a womb and in prison she could
be forced to bear children
so what would they do with these
children well there's
there's a whole movie actually called
hitler's children i mean he was
breeding aryans
part of it of course with him is
self-hatred look at him
you know he's this dark sworthy you know
i mean he was
you could analyze him forever he was
probably half jewish been ashamed of i
mean
you know
but the the point is the larger point i
think for us to remember is that
hierarchies
start with controlling reproduction and
therefore
controlling women's bodies and if there
is racism or
as in india caste
which didn't always exist in india i
mean in the very old
southern part you know it came to mean
it
means color and it was imposed right
then it's much greater because you have
to
keep you have to decide who has children
with whom
in order to keep races separate or
cast separate and so on or visib visible
at least
they did this in is this part
of also even um bloodlines
and royalty and keeping things yes
farms in the family is utter [ __ ]
there is no such thing as royalty excuse
me
yeah royal blood i mean yeah it's a joke
no the whole
idea of kings and queens and all this
hierarchical stuff
is the triangle yeah no i mean it's i
mean it's
at least i mean you may need some
hierarchies like a fire department to
act quickly
i can tell you they don't want to get a
cat out of a tree i've tried that yeah
or a surgical
no but i mean you know you know you need
for purposes of quick action
you may need a hierarchy but the point
is you're not born into that hierarchy
it's about
competence but the hierarchies you're
supposed to be born into
are all utter [ __ ] to use a
technical term
wow um yeah i believe division is a is a
really
um is it's just an area that is
lethal for us and i think we got to get
over that
patriarchy is something else you
mentioned and um
being a you know you being the same you
being the leader of like
women just being themselves and speaking
up
saying what you want but here's the
thing i am also not the leader and
i am part of a movement of course yeah
so
you know i we don't want to repeat the
hierarchy
yeah right like you're you're very
helpful in the process
um but who the hell ever decided
that it was a man not a woman or whoever
decided to have someone in charge like
where did that come from
and how old is that how old is that
problem you said
600 years maybe or something well on
this con and it's older
in other places but because the
european colonists came here about
600 years ago and the and the
you know cultures that were already here
were much more
circular democratic i mean our our
constitution
came from the iroquois confederacy the
haudenosaunee who
we of course we left out women and we
but still the idea of consensus
of circles of consensus came from the
um from here was already here
right so what's the
do you know the history of that or how
the
how that was established i guess it
might i'm i'm finally starting to just
question everything
and um even on the fundamental level um
so
you know men being in power and is like
just uh well no
it's of course it doesn't make sense
it's ridiculous so i'm like i don't get
that anymore like that
doesn't make any sense whoever decided
that and no and actually the the
masculine role is killing men
i mean it's you know it's it may be
harder for women but it's not great for
men either because
you know they're supposed to risk their
lives and tension related diseases and
who knows i mean
they're deprived of their own children
you know i mean part of the way that you
become a whole human being is being able
to
uh you know raise and
love children and relate directly you
know it's not good the rules are not
good for anybody that we figured out
once that men would live five years
longer without the masculine role
because if you just
take out of the statistics the deaths
that are due to
danger speeding tension
so i always say to audiences of men you
know we can offer you
more years of life who else can
do that do that right right and and it's
why you know there are
you know men are feminists too
well i mean that's just the truth
there's masculine and feminine
in every woman and there's masculine and
feminine in every man
and what it seems like is happening is
that
there's a there's i believe there's a
shift to men
getting more in touch with that feminine
side of them
um and the woman of the masculine right
because the masculine
gets things done and goes and does it
and the feminine sits back and kind of
yeah
you know they're both powerful becoming
human
i mean the whole idea of masculine and
feminine is invented i mean
so how would you describe certain
energies then certain
uh human i mean i would i don't know
i guess i would describe their content
nurturing patients
i don't know you know what whatever
the the quality is but i think and
sometimes i think the whole world is
divided into two kinds of people
those who divide everything into two and
those who don't
so i think it probably would be helpful
to at least adventure into not dividing
everything into two
because we aren't actually and and now
and and transgender and trans you know
young people now who are identifying uh
with a a group they are not viewed as
being born into
are very helpful you know because it's
beginning to do away with those
bipartite divisions do you think it's
somewhat
another another division though like
dividing the sections up even more
or is it just about creating awareness
that we're not all like we're not all
one or this
like this or this you know the first
step is probably rejection of the
existing divisions and then you try to
find yourself so
um
i mean i i i know what you mean because
i see
you know on campuses i see young men
trans women who are
uh wearing things that i wouldn't wear
anymore if you know what i mean
because because they seem too feminine
but that's just part of the process of
change probably you know
exploring yeah explain explain to me how
how how how do you
how do you change the assumed
roles identity
or just cultural understanding of
something like what does that process
look like and how long do you think well
i think we're seeing it don't you i mean
yeah you know i mean and you know i'm
way older than you so i just want to say
that
in my life you were supposed to wear uh
skirts and frilly things and
you know just the fact that that we wore
pants when i was growing up was a
rebellion
uh that we didn't wear lipstick i don't
know was
that we didn't wear high heels people
made endless fun of women's asses and
pants
when i was growing up because they were
not supposed to wear so
it's it's uh and men were supposed to be
super
macho in my neighborhood and all of that
so it's it's a
it's so a process but
is there a is there a blueprint for it
is there something where it's like you
come out hard
you wake people up it's got to be
dramatic
whatever it is that you're pushing for
whatever you're trying to
pull the veil back on and then they'll
find a re-center from there
and no there's no no there's no i don't
think
i don't think there's a blueprint like
that i think there is
a kind of um not exactly
blue print but things you can do that
are helpful
for instance if um
if you're in a situation try to remember
especially if you say you're in a
situation which you have more power for
some reason
then be sure to listen as much as you
talk
and if you have less power be sure to
talk as much as you listen
which can be just as hard because you're
not used to used to hiding
so you know the the means are the ends
does that make sense so if we use
something as simple as that
as a little democracy we'll get to
democracy
if you know what i mean okay right
so given that you know there's a
question of
you know all kinds of
constructs that we have do you believe
in duality
no man you keep it really simple it's
kind of hard no
i don't i don't i mean i mean there may
you may be in a situation
where there is a duality but that is a
particular situation
life is not a duality life is
infinite subtlety and circular not
either or that's why i was saying i
think
you know there are two kinds of people
who one who divide
the world into two and yeah yeah i know
so they don't believe in the whole
kind of um light and dark and how that
is
applicable in all situations essentially
like what are you
passing through your life well the day
is not light and dark the day
the day is gradations of light and
gradations of dark and a circle and so
on and the
sun moves around and the moon moves
around right so if it's circular
essentially everything just kind of in
that fashion
you must believe in reincarnation then i
would
i would say no i don't i don't say i
believe because i don't know
so where did we come from and where are
we going i have no idea
what are we living in the present right
here right now
this is it what is us like what i'm what
am i
am i just my body am i
no obvious energy am i like what you're
all of the above
i'm all of the above no scientist has
yet
invented yeah how to create
a human being and i don't think you know
i mean
right yeah there's cloning going on
right yes but that's not the same
i mean you know that's that's a treating
existing i mean
that whatever this life form is it's
taken billions of
years to get there and
no doubt we continue to evolve so what's
the point
the point is us right now sitting here
this is it
[Laughter]
understanding each other learning from
each other
uh respecting each other
recognizing our our both our differences
and our sameness
having ahas of learning which are great
fun
having you know the the old cultures
also
recognized the importance of laughter
they always said that laughter is the
only free emotion
because you can compel fear obviously
you can also compel love if someone is
isolated
and dependent for long enough you come
to believe you're in love because
you bond with somebody in order to
survive
you know it's like the stockholm
syndrome you think that yeah yeah go
into that so love
is well you you they're if
survivalism you know is the key
so if somebody is uh i mean the
stockholm syndrome
as you know was people who were actually
in prison for a long period of time
independent and they
they continued to be attached to their
they were happy there
well they weren't exactly happy but they
were attached and they
they worried about the welfare of their
you know because that's
what we do to survive but the point is
that laughter
can't be compelled it just
happens it's like an orgasm of the mind
you know it just happens
and and here the indian country
cultures say that it's it breaks into
the unknown
and if you can't laugh you can't pray
because it's you know it's a way of
breaking into the unknown
yeah i mean literally you i mean you
can't make some it's the on
you can't make someone laugh actually
really laugh so
it's a great evidence of freedom and
that can guide us too
we should just not go any place we can't
laugh
including churches write that down as
i'm sure you have
um that's um that is uh so what do you
think about love then because i would
the way you described laughter is the
way i feel like
love is described well hopefully that's
also spontaneous and and
free and not compelled right and so on
right
because you can fake laugh which i'm
every now and again accused like
you're fake laughing at me and i'm like
no i'm not yes i am you're right i'm
fake laughing at you yeah well
the very fact that somebody knows it's
fake yeah
means a lot means there's no such thing
as fake laughter or they wouldn't be
able to tell
so then what's uh so love and you think
about there's lots of facets of love
there's love for
you know love for people there's love
for your family there's love for your
dog there's love for things
it's essentially maybe short or shorter
term but
there's a love for doing something
so what about relationships then is this
a construct
are we meant to find one person to share
things with
or is this just part of the part of what
i feel like you're describing is we're
just here to have a human experience
like it's
we're here to laugh we're here to love
we're here to
um experience and learn and share and
grow
so is the relationship part of it
something that we misunderstand
about finding that one yes i mean
the the idea of just one
seems to have come about mainly at least
in western
culture uh
in europe at a in points of time in
which
there was great emphasis on replenishing
the population
the men were frequently in armies and
going off you know the
the amount of time that people were
actually together was quite short
and so there was this intense time of
romance
which is not necessarily the same as
love right
but the kind of mystique of of of love
that we hear
described but i i think in
i would say in romance in love you want
what's best for the other person
in romance you want the other person
okay so it's more about possession
yeah okay and and so ultimately you kind
of want what's best for you because
you're like i just kind of want
well you're you're looking for what's
missing in you
and and the the fact that we divide
ourselves up into masculine and feminine
means that men suppress
their quote-unquote feminine qualities
whatever that means
and we suppress them so then we're
attracted to each other because we're
each
incomplete and this is
this doesn't last of course yeah right
well that's
better if two people are complete
they're way more likely to
yeah stay together that is the journey
isn't it it is the journey to come
to an arrival at yourself
i a few years ago spent enough time
alone to start really figuring myself
out because we
we tend to conform to what we think we
should based on
our job or our family or our
relationship
and and there's so little quiet time now
i mean you can like i find myself i'm
totally guilty of it myself you know you
get a spare minute you look at your
phone
there's never quiet time there's no time
to reflect there's no time to
just quiet the mind and stop being
populated with
propaganda well that's the purpose of of
meditation or whatever i mean it has
many different names but do you
practice no i totally agree in with
meditation i've gone to meditation for
do i meditate no
i have to confess that i do not do you
do something that feels
like it re-centers you mentally
yeah well i i've i value uh
the freedom of living alone and
because i'm a writer that you know my
work is solitary
i also my idea of heaven is an editorial
meeting
because you're all sitting around a
table
trying to think of stories or what's
happening or what should be written or
something and it's a communal
process and i love that you know i think
so do you believe in heaven then
and what do you believe heaven is no i
don't i have no idea
i mean why would i believe in heaven no
i didn't think you'd say yes i just
thought you said heaven i was like
what no my idea of what people think is
heaven
it's not heaven it's right here
it's sitting at a round table not well
the good news is if you don't believe in
heaven there's no hell either no you
know
the whole idea of heaven and hell seems
to have come about
from cultures that we're trying to say
from monotheistic religions okay that
we're saying
okay it's true that women uh
give you give birth and you know
uh but we as a patriarchal religion can
go women one better
we can give you everlasting life that
was not part of the old cultures the old
cultures were more like
you go to the other side of the mountain
and join your
relatives when you die i mean there
wasn't this elaborate
worked out heaven and hell that came
with
patriarchal religions taking the power
of giving birth
um i mean it's that there's a whole
analysis well not just analysis but i
mean where church architecture came from
i mean i read this i didn't make it up
right now enough
of there's um an outer entrance in inner
entrance
labia minora labia majoramino then
there's a vaginal aisle up the center
two curved ovarian structures on either
side
well i don't have to ask you if you
believe in symbolism then an altar
in the middle which is the the womb
where the miracle takes place where men
dressed in skirts like women sprinkle
imitation birth fluid over your head
and say though you were born a woman an
inferior creature so you were born in
sin
[Music]
men the patriarchal religion can go
can do something even better than women
do
which is give you everlasting life
and that seems to be where the idea of
heaven came from
it's relatively new it's blowing my mind
no but i mean when you think about the
you know i'm not trying to oversimplify
but i just it's an insight i think that
that
helps to to understand why it is that
women are not allowed at the altar
why women can't be priests why one a
woman can't be pope
all of it do you think it's gonna change
like do you just are you like yeah
in time or yeah no of course no i think
so
could you even guess how long it would
take no
but it's it's it's changed a fair amount
because there are
fewer believers uh
in terms of numbers i mean you know they
may be very devoted
uh obsessive believers in in a
hierarchical religion
whether it is christian or islamic or
whatever it is
but just in general terms say in this
country
people are not as religious yeah yes
i've gone through my own journey with
that too and i mean when i grew up there
was
no religion i mean it was like my mom
was a lutheran but
you know i i we didn't go to church went
to the racetrack on the weekends and
then i became catholic through a
relationship and
then that went away and i was going to
baptist churches for a while with
someone else and then
now i'm like i saw something called
omnism which is the belief that
no religion is true but there's truth
within all and i'm like that's perfect
because they
they all seem nice but none of them are
to me like i can't
i can't just be all in with one of them
but i think that
they're in my mind again you put things
in such a
elegant way me i'm a little chopped
up but look it's like religions are
somewhat institutions to make money in
my mind or create division
or to a power it's a power thing
and you know i just think that there's
good in all of them
but they they took a turn at some point
in time
well i i think what they all offer which
is really important
is is a community is is being with other
people
and we very much need to be
together i mean we if it's why solitary
confinement is torture you know we
we we need to find a community and they
provide that
but i for myself i make a distinction
between religion and
spirituality yeah so i
is religion to me is a kind of
institution
with some chief and punishment
right right and spirituality is more
like there's godliness in everything
yeah that sounds like what you were
describing more at first
theo say it again theosophy theosophy
yeah
is god knowledge literally but they do
kind of believe there's
because they believe in reincarnation
and i mean it's not all one i don't want
to
oversimplify you know what theosophos
said but
um well you mentioned about community
and um i know empathy
is something that is you know a core
value to you and something that
you said we really need and we need more
of
um can you talk about just why that's an
important attribute
and well important first of all we
couldn't the
human beings couldn't survive without it
you know because
um if we
see if if you put a baby
in the arms of anybody male or female
they're were flooded with oxytocin which
is what the hormone that allows us to
empathize
or if we see an accident in the street
and we want to help even though we don't
know the person
that's being flooded with oxytocin and
empathy
and this human beings couldn't have
survived all these
thousands of years without that without
helping each other
and we we apparently i mean as i asked
my
friendly neurologist we only produce
oxytocin we only empathize when we're
together with all five senses
so when we're looking at a computer
screen we can't we can learn
intellectually but we can't empathize
as much as i love books i have to admit
that you can't empathize
you can learn right and
again as i was saying that's why
solitary confinement is torture
we we can't be alone for like you know
we need
to empathize with each other so is this
and that's in part of our of of the
huge increase in loneliness depression
and suicide
is you can trace to computers and
iphones and you know if i read that
americans are now spending 11 hours a
day on the average
looking at a screen that seems extreme
to me it seems extreme to me
but i don't have a desk job that i would
look at a computer but you know i mean i
do look at my phone
frequently but that's unfortunate yeah
so
that's it so things are taking good
turns but that's not good like
there's only more of that no it's not
it's yeah no it's it's not good and it
does produce depression
and so what's the solution this
the kind of just common sense solution
is to spend an hour with other people
for every hour that you're spending
looking at a screen
i know you don't believe in hierarchy
but i elect you for president
because you have just such a simple but
yet
perfect way to look at things it's just
simple it's like
hi go spend some time with people yeah
well
stop looking at your screen yeah right
but do you think that i mean there's
something these are the regular
humanists it's the reason for instance
we still have theater and we still have
concerts uh because at least
even though there is not a chance to sit
in a circle and
which is the best you know i mean the
most classic
human organization sitting in a circle
and taking turns talking and listening
and everybody gets it
but at least yeah but at least we're
we're all in the same room
right and that still has a magic
right people want to be part of
something i mean generally i think
there's a yearning for that right
there's a yearning for being
in community with someone a part of
something
doing great things growing learning
sharing well just just being with other
human beings but there's so much less of
that i mean like you like you said
there's
people looking at their tv screens
there's people i mean now we just sit
god knows we have all the tv we could
ever want you can watch every
any and every show you want in any
platform now there's everything from of
course
you know cable to you know directv
to netflix hulu uh amazon
apple like you name it there's so many
platforms there's just
less there's more information but less
ways to connect
so look people are going to get this
information
through these platforms so you know
do you still put that connection above
the information
it's not either or it's just that for
every hour that you're sitting
by yourself looking at something
that is inanimate you probably need an
hour
like we're sitting here together right
so do you think that we just get
um we get in bad routines or we get
addicted too easily
because it's hard to turn that off like
as a cognitive
aware person i let it slip and i am
actively trying to
i mean i don't even watch the news
anymore i get up and i'll i'll watch
like a
youtube videos on things that i'm
interested in topics i'm interested in
try and learn but
i don't even watch that anymore and and
i still do it i still
turn my phone on and you know like look
at it and forget to
i know but you you you have you have
invented
something here which means we're here
right so you you know you're
you're doing both you know it isn't it
doesn't have to be either or it can be
and
that's why you put things so simple
you're right i mean it is the
information it's selecting the right
information then right
it's putting in front of you what you it
it'd be great if people
spent their time listening it's not
selecting the right information
you don't know what i'm going to say you
didn't select my information
i don't know what you're going to say
but we're here spontaneously
yeah listening to each other learning
from each other right yeah
yeah very true um
so there's like a main topic that i have
i'm a little like perplexed on and
and that's the topic of feminism and
i had to even look up the definition
that's literally
my awareness level for feminism
i believe in all those things the thing
is i believe in all the things that it
stands for
yet i wouldn't call myself a feminist
well you don't you get to choose
right you do call yourself whatever you
want it
you might say feminism is remedial you
know because we have we live in a
patriarchal
culture uh so we live in a racist
culture so people talk about
black movements and civil rights we live
in a page
it no no it's it's point it's it's it's
if you if you come together when one
group is powerful and the other group is
not
you come together in a hierarchy so you
need
a movement whether it's against racism
or
sexism or whatever it is so you can come
together
at the same level and that's all that
feminism is so
men are feminists just as well as women
are feminists
right because it's a matter of believing
in those values right
and being an activist on some level
to make that a reality right right
anybody can be that person
right so it isn't you know we all get to
choose
our words what whatever it is that that
we want
describes us um but in my heart
i kind of fear that if we
don't understand we're feminists we're
being masochists
because we're putting up with an unjust
system or you can use different
womanists as another word or
a you know egalitarian i mean you know
we don't all have to
choose the same word i mean you're kind
of revolutionizing the way i've
thought about a movement and that's like
that that i don't really
i haven't really thought about a
movement being
a movement points out what's different
about you and the more you talk about
something the more real it is
and i've lived my life in a man's world
but i've never done anything
to like try and highlight like i'm not
trying to
you know be on an all-girl race team or
i'm not trying to i use the attributes i
had to
help with sponsorship and um to
uh you know be able to do my job but i
was never
one to like use it because i still had
to do it regardless like yeah
and the paper was difficult because i
got paid more than are you glad
are you glad to see other women able to
do what you do sure all right that's
feminism
but i'm no i'm it doesn't make me it's
not like i'm thinking to myself when i
see a woman out there i'm not thinking
yeah i'm thinking someone is
following their dreams and i believe in
that that's a big i believe
in that's a yeah but it could be for a
man too
i could have the same yeah like you're
from a small town you don't have a
famous lesson
but if you've been kept out of the race
because you're a female or because
you're black or because you're asian or
because you're gay or because you're
you know then you're you're you know
you're left at the starting
line no i i didn't have to go through
that period of time
so what's it like now is it 50 50 women
no
oh no no there was one one girl in the
indy 500 this year
we had as many as five one year which
was a lot
um but that's it sometimes there's none
um
i actually made the mistake of saying
last year there wasn't oh yeah that was
me i was the one in it last year
um but yeah there's there's there's no
females on the regular circuit as far as
like
indycar and nascar at the highest level
um
what made you want to do it
um yeah so it's interesting because i i
wouldn't say that i love racing like
that wasn't
my motivating factor actually my dad
said he's like
you need a job and you're good at it
what i loved
what i loved about racing was that
i loved setting setting a goal and
achieving it i loved the journey
i loved the hope i loved hoping that
every single season i started
was an opportunity to do better than the
year before and
i just loved that progression so the
joys in the journey was something that
was so true for me
so for me at the end i didn't feel like
i had an opportunity to do
to do better than i had done and so for
me the part i loved was gone
and i'm like i'm okay with that and i'm
someone that is okay with change
so i was able to move on at a you know
young
do you think what made you pick this
field racing uh uh
probably my dad um my dad raced when he
was younger and then
my sister actually was the one who
wanted to start go-kart racing she quit
within a few months of starting because
she didn't enjoy it
and basically got driven over the top of
so she didn't she didn't like that and
so
i kept going and you know made a career
out of it but
i mean it really does come from my dad
and
he still loves it he still loves it more
than i love it you know he's the one
that still goes to the track even though
i'm not out there and he's
like he arrives and goes see ya and he
goes and runs around and does his
mingling and
as like i think he well i do think we
we do what we see yeah you know we need
role models and
you know we we as they say we have to
see it to be it so
you saw this in your father and and
were able to do it and enjoy it and so
on and now you've gone on
to do things your father doesn't do he
doesn't sit here probably
no right now i interviewed him and i was
like i'm trying to go deep on him i'm
like dad and this night he's like
i'm like okay you know it's just uh you
know he
doesn't go deep like that what do you
think about nature versus nurture then
what do you mean like you know you're
born with
certain qualities as if you remember
those qualities maybe
no it's versus what you see
i think it's both i don't think once
again i think the world is divided into
two kinds of people
those who divide everything into two and
those who don't okay
so it's not so you divide a little it's
not nature versus nurture
it's nature and nurture right
so we come into the world as a unique
human being you can't change that
uh you can frustrate that you can break
that
you can develop that you can love and
glorify that you can do a lot of things
but you can't change completely
the unique person who came into the
world do you think you can change a lot
not change you can choose which part to
develop maybe
right obviously our childhoods are very
very important because our brains are
not completely developed
uh until we're in our early 20s
so you know we're still making
connections and synapses and
and i mean the brain is physically
growing
for a years after birth
so we're way more influenced by our
childhood than other animals
who are independent much sooner
you know foals i mean you know horses
the little newly born horse gets up and
walks around right away
people do not do that yeah right right
right right
so that you know because the human brain
is so big
and you it can't get through the birth
canal
uh it it a lot of it develops
in in childhood and that makes us
very vulnerable to the influences around
us
but it it's also true that you can't
completely change
the person who who is there in that baby
there's a person inside every baby
the essence of the person right
um i heard something that
in our first seven years that we're
alive
and the last trimester of pregnancy
as a baby that that is your subconscious
programming
and after that you have to go in and
reprogram
which would explain why it's really
difficult to figure out why you have
certain patterns i feel like because
you're like i don't remember being four
like you know but there are certain
things that we do where we are
we're probably dealing with old stuff
that we don't remember
um i'm very interested in the human mind
and
and the ability to reprogram and the
ability to program the ability to
um create our world
i don't know if program is subtle enough
though it was a word do you think
i mean we as infants we need to be held
if we need right it's it's very
very sensory we need
faces to look at you know to connect to
um babies also
uh empathize right away even with other
babies
you know if you if you put babies
together
uh they will you know touch each other
smile at each other
share food you know
yes so yeah so so
you know those it's kind of comforting
to think that yeah they're more empathy
than
yourself
their baby than they are to an adult do
they find is there more empathy for
another
existence just like theirs or is it is
there some is there
because you know i don't know i don't
know if there's any such experiment i
have no idea
but but there is uh something uh
about babies that want to look at
another face i don't know
yeah right that their their parents face
another baby's face i don't know but
there's
we are filled with oxytocin from the
beginning
we empathize we want to touch we want to
learn we
want to right we can't
babies that are isolated don't develop
if they're left in a crib even though
they're fed
yeah you know there have been
terrible terrible instances
of um in eastern european countries that
we're trying to force
when perhaps other places that we're
trying to force women to have a lot of
children
and keep them in cribs and you know a
kind of an
almost industrial production it was
tragic because the kids didn't develop
as they should have right this kind of
brings me back to almost what you said
well it was what you said at the
beginning about not going to school
for a long time until you said 13 12 13.
well i would go
until it got cold and then we would get
in our house trailer and
go off but that you
that my understanding is that you didn't
really think about
the differences between people and being
a woman
until you started going to school and
then it all of a sudden became
something important and and
well i thought about i mean i was re i
was with my family i had an older sister
nine years older had my parents i you
know i was
with grown-ups uh which probably gave me
a
vocabulary that was off-putting to my
to other kids um you can imagine so you
learn
you know not not to do that but
uh i don't think
i i mean of course what i was reading
was very gendered
too because i mean because
because if even if you're reading louisa
may alcott and little women which is a
whole society of women
you still notice that it's the man who's
going off to war and the women who are
binding up the wounds and
so so i was certainly
exposed to gender but i wasn't
constantly being told you can't do that
right you know you can't uh wear that
because
i mean i i remember being taken into
an old department store to buy
shoes and
they somebody was trying to get me to
buy mary jane's
you know what mary jane's yes they came
into fashion about 10 years ago again
and and i wanted red sneakers and no way
was i going to wear
so you know that was partly a result of
just
right and i wanted a cowboy hat and i
wanted what did school do then
why what did school do to make you go oh
yeah i'm not supposed to do that i'm not
supposed to have red shoes
well you know they're the classic primer
in my era and for many years after was a
dick and jane
it was literally two characters named
dick and jane
and uh dick was the active one
going up the hill and jane was trailing
at me you know
it was all about gender and they were
very white these kids
so that was was that the
the vibe or was this just the curriculum
i mean it's
the curriculum no it's the correct do
you think there's a problem with it of
course
yeah no no no because it limits people i
mean
you know we still have big problems with
textbooks
because uh you know there's still
textbooks are partly written by who
orders them
exactly and and texas i think is the
biggest order of
texas and not everybody in texas is
always happy that the south lost
they might rewrite it it's not exactly
but it may be
written in a different way you know as
to as to what the war was about
have you read the i haven't read it but
i know i i know
about the book but 1984 have you read
that book
um that was orwell so that was a
different yeah
and but it was talking about basically
being able to rewrite history like as
a as a again i haven't read the book and
i do want to read the book
um it was actually in a hotel room in
new york city and it said if you want to
be a rebel and take this book
we'd love you to take it like it'll be
ten bucks but you know
and i was like this is a sign i should
take this book 1984 it was the 1984
well george o'rourke was warning against
the conformity
of communism that he saw
arriving on the scene and trying to make
a case
for the uniqueness and individuality
that was being sacrificed right wasn't
there a portion of it that had to do
with basically
writing history like being able to have
the ability to rewrite the memories of
stories
as they're going in the way that someone
wanted them to be yeah no the state
yeah big big brothers yeah the state the
state was rewriting everything and you
got the
version that they wanted you to have
instead of what you actually experienced
which i mean he
he created a dystopian society in order
to
warn people away from totalitarian
methods right right do you um
do you have a favorite book there are a
couple of them
um oh gosh there's but there are too
many
to i mean you know i have favorite
authors i mean alice walker is one of my
favorite authors
because her poetry and her novels and
you know she somehow includes everything
people nature if i wanted to read a book
about
um
oh way to live life like a
a guide almost what would be a good book
for that
yourself no book be a good author
no my own story no just what you love to
do
what what do you you love what do you
love so much you forget what time it is
when you're doing it
yeah that's a good way of learning that
that's what you're supposed to be doing
how do you have the energy
at the 85
great young age of 85 right right right
to as i've read have a dozen
projects going on at one time i mean
that's just
i don't have a dozen projects and i'm 37
so and i feel like i'm really busy right
now
tell me like you have a lot of projects
no but
how how do you manage it because i love
it
because i love it i don't manage very
well i'm not saying
i'm always late with my deadlines i've i
have to live to a hundred
just to get me my deadline
well inspiration is natural but it's
because
two things one i'm doing what i love and
two i get seduced by the idea that maybe
we could solve this if we did this and
that you know it's so
interesting you look at a problem you
think okay maybe if we did this or that
or the other thing and if you called
this person and if they only knew each
other and if you said
it's fun it's just infinitely
interesting
and and and also you're fueled by
unfairness
you know when you see something that is
just completely
yeah unfair you know it just makes you
mad enough
to try to do something about it yeah
right
strong motivation yeah no right
i mean i maybe you could have predicted
your life a little bit more because
you saw what your father was doing and
it interested you and you wanted to do
it
but probably from now on you won't be
able to predict your life
yeah maybe yeah maybe you're right
because there was some kind of a
a model for it um
[Music]
a way to see it yeah you said that we
believe it when we see
it essentially right didn't you say that
earlier or something about that
uh something something well you have to
you have to see it to be
it see it to be yeah you don't know it's
possible always unless you see it yeah
so because i believe that essentially
like
when i believe it i'll see it
which is maybe not exactly the same on
the flip side but
but what do you what do you think about
that what do you think about the power
of
believing in something so much that you
i'm just going to like manifest or force
them what's an example i mean believing
is something you've never seen
visualizing and seeing something through
like let's say
my winery you know when i was standing
on
the knoll of quintessa in 2006 swirling
my white wine before noon
i uh may have been before 11 even and i
looked down the valley and i thought to
myself
i'm gonna have something i want to have
something like this someday
i don't have 50 million dollars right
now but someday i might
and i'd love to have something like this
someday and i started dreaming
into what that looked like and i have it
and it didn't cost 50 million thank god
but i started dreaming into it and i
started visualizing it
which this is the slight this isn't this
is why it's not an exact flip because i
saw something i liked
and then i just started visualizing how
i wanted to see it
well i think that's why yeah i mean you
you saw something that was possible
i mean maybe if you never ever ever ever
saw a vineyard
you might not have had the idea i had
the idea or wanted to you know because
we need a little yeah
but then you could take that idea and
and make it your own
so you you see it to be it but you also
make it your own
well what did you see then when you were
younger that made you go
men and women are just construct like
why are we well i didn't think that when
i was younger i mean you're kidding me
no
i didn't it took me a while to figure
that out i mean i
i for years you know well into my
until i was 40 uh at least
i kept thinking okay i'm gonna do what
women are supposed to do
i'm gonna get married and have children
and live that life
just not right now so i just kept
putting it off and putting it off and
putting it off
and one day i realized i was happy
and fortunately the whole of feminism
came along
and said not everybody has to live the
same way
it's okay
and it's not better or worse it's a
different you can you know you you don't
all have to do the same thing
um i'm gonna read a part from
uh your by the the introduction for
your uh your book which i love the title
the truth will set you free but first it
will piss you off in a book of quotes
yes that's i'm i'm just and i love
quotes right
in my book which i might as well just
hand it over to you right now
um there's a you know ambitious workout
program in there and some other things
but the first five chapters are more
mind-body connected
um but uh but
i haven't i have a chapter on mantras
quotes you know
even developing your own there's like a
mantra marker at the end of it where you
can kind of create some
you know put down some attributes that
you love to create something that's
meaningful to you so
i'm just saying this this may help me i
don't think so meditate to have a mantra
thank you
a little remedial for you maybe but um
but
uh but the point is is that i love
quotes
and um i'm really excited about this
book
but i thought i would kind of this this
this this
sort of towards the end of the
introduction i love this part
um this is talking about sort of the uh
you know you're talking about the
patriarchy kind of
um world we live in and and the uh
the difficulties that it produces so
just as the family
just as the family and the source of
everything from violence to democracy
it's also a teaching lesson here
for a woman in a violent household the
most dangerous time
is just before or after she escapes this
is when she's most likely to be injured
or killed why
because she's escaping control the
majority of this country
are escaping control of old hierarchies
of race and gender
and more the meaning this the
this means two things first we need to
be aware
and look after each other love that
second
we may be about to be free i mean that's
the truth
and that's just that was when i read
that i'm like i'm gonna circled it i'm
like i love that no i'm
i'm so glad because i think that
you know from looking at the microcosm
you learn the
macrocosm and i yeah sure you know from
from looking at domestic violence i i
began to see that
and i i think part of what we have not
done
is to at least not done enough is to
recognize
that the most dangerous time is after a
victory
you know because you are about to be
free and um
i mean for instance lynching did not
happen
during slavery it happened after
emancipation
and the whole time of reconstruction
after emancipation was about
reinstituting economic slavery
and using lynching and so on to do that
and i
i i think in our current situation
we didn't understand that well enough
because
just in general the social justice
movements all of them
and the environmental movement zone have
changed the majority
opinion in this country
and on top of that we had had
eight years of the obama administration
so why didn't we anticipate that a third
of the country
that still believes in the old way and
feels deprived of the old hierarchy and
you know i mean not to oversimplify but
that's
a lot of the reason was going to
be in bed i don't think we understood
that
you know we we celebrate a victory
without understanding
that there's going to be a backlash
well looking after each other
and all of my travels and all the people
that i've met and all the differences
that exist
what i always find is a good human like
for the most part
look there are some there are some bad
ones but for the most part when you
travel and when you meet new people
and whatever side of the the
the the the um the duality you're on
like
you know sorry whatever side of the
the the the this or that whether it's
you know republican democrat or whether
it
is
you know yeah you find good people right
you find good people
i'm just objecting after each other i'm
just objecting to the duality part
okay scratch that and strike that no i
mean you don't have to scratch it but i
would just say
you know that that um dualities are
based on masculine feminine which are
black and white or whatever
you know which is part of the problem
not the solution
the point is look after each other right
like that take care of each other
we all have the same goal in mind
usually which is be happy
be joyful find peace and then the second
being we're about to be free i mean
there's
the only way to the other side is
through you know we have to go through
when you're in the middle of it is
probably almost the most hopeful time
because there's
it means you're on the way and so
it's a hopeful time for sure um so maybe
you can and
which is i'm not so good about this you
probably given your profession are
better living in the present
because our minds get occupied with what
if
in the future or why did i do that in
the past or whatever
and it happens you can only be fully
alive in the present yeah
um eckhart tolle talks a lot about that
and it's uh
i listen to him and i love listening to
his boys it's so entrancing and
um but you know when he's he's talking
about it
i think but i won't get anything done
there that's what i'm thinking i'm like
but if i'm just in the present and
nothing no because it's happening i
won't get anything done there
yeah no but you will because you because
you will be building the block of the
next
thing and you know rather than divided
half your head is in the future and well
maybe
when i drove i was able to get the
present better
yes it sounds to me yes right it sounds
to me like a great form of meditation
you can't you don't have any time
no i think that's that's terrific right
so i've taken a lot of your time and i
appreciate it but maybe you could
kind of give to me your um
your grand vision of how you know if you
were to able to
cast your magic wand and say this is
what i hope
mankind looks like woman-kind man
humankind
let's give it a non-name let's give it a
human kind
yeah that's a very good name how does it
look it's not a very good name
uh
well it looks like a circle
that does not only contain humankind
but all the plants and animals and all
the
living things on earth and
there is at least the beginning of an
understanding
that we are all linked yeah
in a circle we are not ranked like this
yeah
right beautiful thank you so much gloria
no
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click on the subscribe
button
you